easiest way to ask a closed question in  a sale which is where everyone always  chokes is simply asking would it be  totally crazy for us to move forward  today would you be totally opposed to us  moving forward today or would you be  totally opposed to us moving forward at  the end of this call should be totally  opposed moving forward period when you  ask it like that it's not saying hey do  you want to sign up or hey do you want  to pay or hey do you want to buy right  now we're saying would you be opposed to  moving forward and then the person can  feel safe and say well i'm not opposed  to moving forward and you're like  awesome boom you get it and you can move  forward with the paperwork and that's  one of the easiest ways to ask for a  sale that's low pressure